muslims in norway are now establishing a
masjid and dawa center to enhance the
norwegian dawah if you donate to the
schools you will ensure allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra rewards
how are you doing i came across this
fascinating video fascinating at least
to me
because it put things in perspective and
i wanted to share it with you and react
to it um for you
so let's first take a look at this video
and then come back and comment on it
libraries also have evolved the assyrian
library of ascerbanipal had thousands of
clay tablets
the celebrated library of alexandria in
egypt consisted of almost a million
papyrus scrolls
great modern libraries like the new york
public library contain some 10 million
books
that's more than 10 to the 14th bits of
information in words more than 100
trillion bits and if we count pictures
it's something like 10 to the 15th bits
of information
now that's more than 10 000 times the
total number of bits of information in
our genes
something like 10 times the total amount
of information in our brains
if i were to read a book a week for
my entire adult lifetime and i
lived an ordinary lifetime when i was
all done
i would have read maybe a few thousand
books
no more
in this library
that's
from about here
roughly
to about
here
but that's only
a tenth of a percent or so of the total
number of books in the library
the trick is
to know which books
to read
but they're
all here
all right so basically when i was
looking at this video for the first time
i think it really relieved me and it put
things in perspective
because
i mean for me
uh honestly like when i used to go into
bookshops and libraries it used to be
quite a stressful experience for me
because i used to think to myself wow
i've got all these books that i haven't
read and where am i going to start and
all these kinds of things and just like
many people do with me nowadays i used
to ask a lot of people can i have
reading lists can i what book do i start
with i want to become cultured i want to
increase my cultural capital and when i
want to become more all-rounded when it
comes to reading and knowledge and all
these kinds of things
and then
i realized that this was actually the
wrong kind of approach
in the sense that i think a lot of us
just want to know everything or want to
be able to converse with people on any
topic that's not really how it works
how it works is first you have to admit
that you won't be able to do that i mean
this video really puts that in
perspective because
you can't be a specialist in every field
i mean i i remember reading
in fact
al ghazali said uh our scholar
he said that in two years he was able to
kind of
exhaust the philosophical cannon of his
day
that's two years i mean nowadays that's
basically impossible to even trying to
exhaust the
the western philosophical cannon in 20
years
is is pretty much impossible
so because of the sheer
level of
amount of information that we have
nowadays it's not really possible to
exhaust anything
the real question you should ask is the
following
what knowledge contribution do i want to
make in this world
and that relates to knowledge production
so what do you want to make even in
knowledge contribute if not then maybe
there's another question which is
what do i want to know
okay
what do i want to know obviously from
our perspective as muslims there's
nothing that defeats or can be better
than or supersedes the quran and the
sunnah firstly the quran and the sunnah
and in fact
it's verging on the disrespect you
almost think that you will find wisdoms
greater than
uh to be honest it's called to believe
this the quran or the sunnah because we
believe this is the ultimate guidance
anything that is outside of it will not
provide us with guidance that's not in
the quran
or sunnah so that's our perspective if
you spent your whole life
just reading the quran and sunnah you
would not be wasting your time
so this is our perspective obviously as
non-muslims are watching this i would
say even from your perspective
if you haven't come across the quran and
sun or the seer of the prophet or the
lifetime or biography of the prophet
it would it would be kind of absurd to
live a whole life not knowing what a
quarter of the world's population
believe and see as sacred
this would render you actually
culturally
uncultured
weakened from a cultural capital
perspective so reading the quran and the
sunnah and of course the religion or the
religious books of other great faiths is
something where everyone can
can do it and should do it
having said this though going back to
the two questions i asked number one
what knowledge contribution do you want
to make
or and or
what knowledge do you want to acquire
once you've got this question then you
can reverse engineer the issue
so
what book should i read is a secondary
question to those
most important questions what do i want
to do
and in fact i would say put it into
timeline format i mean we have 168 hours
in the week we have 24 hours in the day
we have 365 days in the year
where are you going to be in the next
five years or the next 10 years
where do you want to be in the next five
years or 10 years
if you don't have a plan for yourself
then you won't get anywhere if you fail
to plan plan
to fail
so you need to reverse engineer the
process i want to know this i want to
know that i want to know this why do you
want to know it because if you have a y
as nietzsche said then almost any how is
possible
so to have a strong justification for
what it is you want to learn and then
you have to reverse engineer your
learning process
and you'll know what books to read now
having said that looking at this video
you'll realize that you can't read all
the books
in in say for example one subject if
you're a physicist you cannot read all
you cannot exhaust
all of the physics books
if you are this someone
hadith specialist you cannot read all
the books of hadith
with the
periphery books and the books of ayala
and this book and the
the all the books of rajal you will not
be able to do that
so then you have to start becoming
selective smart worker
and that requires that's a skill in and
of itself
there are some books which you can read
and will read or should read cover to
cover and other books where you won't be
able to do that and if you do that
you'll be uh spending your energy in the
wrong places it'll be an inefficient
kind of use of resources here
so you have to start knowing how to use
content pages and indexes
you have to start looking at okay this
is what the reader what this is what the
writer wants me
to know
but what do i want to know from the
writer
or the author of this book
what do i want to know from the author
of this book so you have to start
approaching books especially the
voluminous compendious um you know books
in that way
once you've started to orchestrate that
then you actually start to carve out for
yourself
a knowledge production which will be
beneficial not just yourself but to all
those around you
but once again if you don't have a plan
for the next five years or ten years of
what you want to achieve then
unfortunately you're just going to be a
free floater
you're going to
be an individual in the in the sea uh on
the ship letting the wind take you
wherever it may
you're not going to be steering the
direction where that ship is going to go
you're going to be a helpless swimmer
or not even
a swimmer but in fact a floater in the
ocean of major waves
but you need to learn how to swim and
the only way to know how to swim is to
have a destination in mind
so from that perspective
plan your direction
once you do that and once you know for
me personally when i did that i realized
that quite frankly life started to
become a bit more organized
i felt more and more achievement in my
life reading what i need to read
i didn't feel like reading was
a tedious or laborious
um or difficult enterprise it was
something which led to my steady
development and led to an ultimate
objective or goal
which i obviously still haven't achieved
in and that's something which you can
continue renewing every five or ten
years
i hope this
this video
was interesting to you because i found
that particular video very very
interesting because
looking at things from a macro
perspective
puts things in perspective
muslims in norway are now establishing a
masjid and dawa center to enhance the
norwegian tawa if you donate to the
scores you will ensure allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra rewards
you